hey what's up guys my name is Joe know
and love them day is tomorrow so let's
talk about it right now so what is a lot
of their first of all for those of you
who do not know which is hard to believe
it may be there are a few people who
don't know what love them there is still
lot um dere is a 48-hour game
programming competition in which you
basically have 48 hours to make a game
right from scratch based on a particular
theme that is released when the
competition starts so I don't know what
the theme is yet I will know in 14 hours
25 minutes and 55 seconds for me
recording this so basically the idea is
you have to be a 48 hours man to make a
game based on particular theme
everything has to be made from scratch
so obviously i'll be making the game
from scratch from scratch doesn't mean
you know just from 0 is in you know how
to use any engines or anything you're
still allowed to use game engines and
all that stuff obviously you don't have
to write it in binary from scratch but
then we're an assembly or something you
can use best whatever you like you can
even use unity I don't like unity so I
have a use unity but some you've
welcomed to use that the idea is you
have 48 hours making but everything has
to be made from scratch to the code all
that stuff the idea the concept of
course has to be developed in that time
i dled all the assets the sprites the
music so i'll be i'll be doing all that
stuff right i'll be writing the code
obviously i'll be i'm making all the
sprites i'll be making the sounds i'll
be writing and producing music and all
that will be live streamed ok i'll be
live streaming that entire process like
I do every time Laden dare happens so
the live stream will take place at
twitch.tv fall / the cherno so make sure
you follow me on there and make sure you
check back basically just bookmark that
page if you don't want to miss a stream
bookmark that page and keep checking
back to it all throughout this weekend
because i'll be streaming more often
than not basically ok what else are the
number one question that everyone always
asks me is what are you going to use to
make the game ok and that is you that is
an insanely difficult question to answer
because i don't know what game
make it right it's like when you come up
to someone it's like let's just say
you're going to make a game right you
have no idea what the game is but you're
like I'm gonna make a game and then
someone asks you well what are you gonna
use to make it like well I don't know it
kind of depends on the game that I'm
gonna make right if I'm are you know I
might use a variety of different tools I
might use them if it's a 3d game I might
you know probably end up using something
like OpenGL if it's just a 2d like kind
of low-resolution kind of game boy color
style pokemon game I might just use Java
2d and or just a Java graphics and
actually have like a pixel array
rasterization thing going on right
because I don't need massive performance
or hardware acceleration so there's like
I don't know what I'm going to use yet
um regarding the chernobyl engine though
because i said i was definitely going to
use that i haven't had time to finish
that so it's it's it's any semi use it's
in a usable state I'm not gonna lie it's
like there's nothing that there aren't
really no bugs in it that would prevent
you from using it as an actual library
okay I haven't made it a release yet but
the code is on github of course and the
idea is that it's not up to up to point
but the thing is like if I do end up
going with a kind of pixel array game
i'm probably use journal engine for that
because i've written a whole bunch of
code there so it is in a usable state
it's just not it's nowhere near finished
its i wouldn't call it usable for anyone
who doesn't know how the engine works
because you'll have to write basically
extensions for the engine even to use
simple things like collision right now
but yeah so I don't know what I'm going
to use okay I don't know you guys will
see when i start the stream okay because
when i start this dream when I come up
with this a good idea and I decide what
I'm going to use you guys will find out
that way okay that's that's the deal I
don't know what I'm going to use yet it
could be really crazy i could be
something completely different i could
even use C++ don't know why I would
because I've only got 48 hours to make
that game and see those plus of course
is quite slow to develop in but yeah so
that's what that's what laden Daris okay
you have it's pretty epic you have a
very limited amount of time I like
sleeping
and I know this commentary is coming
trailing off here but I like sleeping so
I sleep for at least eight hours during
a lot of there so I don't even care
about that so I'm doing 70 pulling
all-nighters or anything I'll be in bed
under my duck feather blankie blanket
and just does enough so that's the idea
but I will be streaming whenever I'm
developing it and it won't just be the
code either um I know a lot of you
people like to see me make the graphics
for game so that obviously will be there
I know that an even larger amount of you
actually like watching me write the
music for us so that will be live
streamed as well so whatever you're
interested in in terms of the game
development process I have 48 hours to
make a game start to finish all that
will be broadcasted and I think that's
all I wanted to say so twitch.tv for the
journal it starts at 11am sterling is
instead of time tomorrow morning that
saturday morning if you guys don't know
what time it starts in your time zone
you can go to Luud and datacom for such
comparable link will obviously be in the
description so will the twitch link if
you go to London de NOC home for / compo
that is like a countdown timer to win it
begins so you can just just go to that
you'll see when it begins because that's
roughly when i'll start streaming
hopefully i'll be able to start
streaming maybe 15-20 minutes before it
starts and that is about it ok i also i
would highly recommend that you follow
me on twitter twitter the comforts at
the Chernobyl goes wrong like some
reason maintenance down or I can't stop
live stream updates to my situation and
everything will be posted on Twitter of
course so twitter.com foresight eterno
again link in the description ok anyway
it should be an amazing weekend I can't
I love love them there it's like my
favorite it's definitely my favorite
game programming I guess event or game
development event um every year i've
done this is my fifth time doing it and
hopefully and when i'm gonna make the
best game i've ever made so there you go
I'll see you guys tomorrow goodbye